خلينا نروح الى لبنان قبل ذلك سالنا الناس
هناك اذا لديك يوم اجازه اضافي في الاسبوع
شو راح تستغله او الى
[موسيقى]
فرصه يوم ممكن اروح بقى الاماكن انا لسه
ما روحتهاش يعني بس يعني لو كنت موجود يوم
زياده كنت هصحى الصبح بدري وانزل البحر
بس كده اذا كان نهار فرصه زياده بدي
نشتغله لانه شايفه المعيشه كيف صايره هاي
هي معمل لحق يعني
رياضه
بحب الرياضه
مضعف حالي لو كان عندي يوم فرصه زياده
بالاسبوع بطلع بالظهر انا وحبيبتي وامي
والعائله يعني هيك لو كان عندي يوم
ما بخلي
شو بدي اعمل
نعيش ونشوف الحياه انا اشتغلت 40 سنه
بالكولاج
ما كنت اعرف شو في بره بس هلا بحب بيتي ما
بحب اظهر اذا صح لي يوم زياده بالجمعه
اكيد بقضيه معايلتي
ونحن قاعدين عاطلين عن العمل شو بدي اعمل
فيه نحن
اعطونا حتى نشتغل حتى
[موسيقى]
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات